el juicio abrió esta mañana aquí en
París a más de cuatro décadas de los
hechos y en ausencia del único acusado
se trata de hassan diab un profesor de
sociología libanés canadiense de casi 70
años que se declaró inocente y se negó a
comparecer sin excusa válida según el
tribunal especial de lo penal de la
capital francesa es un litigio inusual
porque se juzga al presunto culpable en
Rebeldía las razones que Francia ni
siquiera emitió una orden de extradición
y ahí radica Otro aspecto particular del
juicio Esta es la segunda vez que diab
debería sentarse en el banquillo de los
acusados la primera fue en 2014 luego de
que el gobierno canadiense aceptara
entregarlo pero tras un proceso que
demoró seis años y tensó las relaciones
entre Ottawa y París Qué ocurrió en
aquella ocasión un juez antiterrorista
invalidó la investigación por falta de
pruebas las huellas digitales del
acusado nunca fueron encontradas en la
escena y varios testigos afirman que se
presentó a exámenes universitarios en el
Líbano en la fecha del atentado en
contra suya además de informes de
inteligencia los fiscales utilizan un
retrato hablado hecho por El vendedor de
la motocicleta que explotó en la
sinagoga ese dibujo corresponde con el
físico de diap pero no con el nombre ni
la nacionalidad del comprador curioso
eso sí que el pasaporte es real del
acusado fuera encontrado en España un
año después de los hechos con estampas
de entrada y salida coincidentes con la
fecha del atentado en cualquier caso
diap Está lejos de verse tras las rejas
Aún si fuese declarado culpable el
gobierno de Justin trudeau se niega a la
extradición de ciudadanos canadienses
adicionalmente la organización no
gubernamental amnistía internacional
instó a la fiscalía antiterrorista
francesa a que retire los cargos Porque
tanto la justicia canadiense como la de
este país han determinado en el pasado
que no hay pruebas creíbles en su contra
El veredicto se conocerá en apenas tres
semanas